o latitude pessoal daqui quem fala é o
dar que seja muito bem vindo
jamais um vídeo e o estrago de que nós
timóteo é um jogo de empurra
completamente a foto frank hoje com o
advogado como vocês podem ver o dodô é
curta eo número de vetores muito bem
vamos lá embora pessoal porque este jogo
é bizarro e nós temos que andar porque
se ficarmos parados
eu fui atrás de nós não se esqueçam que
aqui existe o zé da bolacha e outros
bichos com uma cara muito estranha que
andou atrás nós ou sangue no auditório
além do chile para shatwan outras sair
daqui o usando a tim está popular
shamell de bolacha amigo ajuda por favor
eu tenho que encontrar uma saída dele
porque tem choraram a mim não não não
chora porque olha pra mim não não eu vou
ficar muito tempo perdeu vamos embora
daqui psol não sei se vou voltar para
trás dele que é um time novo anel que
voltei para trás e tem que pôr onde fez
curso de língua pessoal mas foi
derrubado e morto em uma pontinha da
língua meu
agora veja também para o botafogo no
topo se ver o que é que eu tenho que
fazer o outro acusado de idade
a intelecta tucci eo rio rock e estou
contente por ver disse que caraças não
estava sic da forma que ele tem que ir
embora não tem que ir embora não consiga
estar aqui olá amigos e não quer fazer
mal estar foi o vídeo isto amigos
o fim hoje acontecem plano existem casas
de mel em cancún vai explodir e que o
buraco é caála porta a bater ok pessoal
tá ali uma luz vai perceber que qualquer
coisa eu sei que eu vou lá pra trás
primeiro antes de apanhar que o pulinho
outra vez muito obrigado em milk shake
que consegue ficar para botafogo e estou
separada há prémios não tiram os olhos
de mim
ok ok eu não faço mal amigos faladas
time passar vai lá por favor eu sou
filho de deus de um questões não também
não vou passar por todos possam estar
presas
a planta desapareceu o que é porque
agora já não sei por onde é que o
twitter pessoal
as luzes se apagaram já não ser por aí o
tio alguém de um país joaquim eu não
faço mal por favor é essa porta vai
explodir à minha frente mas tem que ter
algumas portas só quem fica
completamente escuro vai precisar de
bicho eu sair eu sei do meu eu não sei o
que é isso mas eu passar fome pessoal
irmã dele e roubaram ao uso
é não um estudo na medo não no medo como
baratas agora está exemplo acha ser
baratas é tudo aqui meu
calma lá da faca não há portas aqui
amigos por favor eu gosto de vocês
um mágico melksham eu tenho que seguir
os cogumelos há uma luz vou ganhar
aquilo vai fazer um bicho mais
corredores eu não faço em só caiu porque
vou porque a minha escolha esta ok vou
pra quem não porque aprendi uma franquia
e uol que o meu ok era porque eu não
consigo entrar aqui vão ter na minha
lanterna já nascendo agora como é que eu
vou entrar aqui para lá abriu a porta a
tap chaval kaita fechada e vou ter que
mostrar agora essa lei interna porque se
pressupõe como a eterna mel go tube mais
bicho já que o meu
olá amigos que eu tenho para tony jorge
este jogo assusta completamente pelo som
porque é que os olhos nos olhos do linda
a emel apanha achava isso agora fica
escuro e perigoso esta deve ser uma
daquelas portas obviamente o tofu
quitutes um livro meu era estar aqui
tudo certo bolacha a porta calma
deixando passar a me falar eu preciso me
manter na porta de outra vez não
consegui nada meu
portanto lá posso passar obrigado nenhum
painel interna isso acredita que o papel
que lhes a este é o meu mundo um mundo
feito de tijolos de cogumelos no chão e
se esta populacional em pra mim vamos
embora daqui pessoal qualquer outro
papel não terão que o papel é o que
disse é é não conseguir suportar muito
porque vamos avançar pessoal para lá
nós temos que conseguir sair daqui a
lusa bateu também apostou no meu hotel
foi pela tam que por onde tem que
prometer que por onde e por que e por
que trocar um de estepe fundo isto não é
capa eu tenho que andar há muito tempo
carlos
o outro fogo ok ok então aqui ao menos
nos fantasmas meu mas consegui passar
por estudos
ok porque mata quero lançar o jogo isso
eu andei este tempo todo para encontrar
uma bruxa
então é isso pessoal nós vamos ficar por
aqui com esse noxt moro só foi sempre um
curto é e acabou assim forma única de um
estranho mas é isso pessoal espero que
tenham gostado fiquem bem e até a
próxima